WANTED TO GIVE YOU A LOOK AT
WHAT’S HAPPENING AHEAD OF THIS
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND.
A "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER HAS
SPARKED OUTRAGE WITH A TWEET
CLAIMING THE THEORY THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS ORIGINATED FROM A
LAB IN WUHAN, CHINA, IS RACIST.
SHE TWEETED THURSDAY, SOMEDAY WE
WILL STOP TALKING ABOUT THE LAB
LEAK THEORY AND MAYBE EVEN ADMIT
IT’S RACIST ROOTS.
BUT ALAS, THAT DAY IS NOT YET
HERE.
"THAT REPORTER WHO MAINLY COME
FROM IRIS THEN DELETED A TWEET
SAYING IT WAS "BADLY PHRASED."
SENATOR TED CRUZ JOINED THE
OUTCRY WITH THIS.
"THIS IS THE SCIENCE REPORTER
FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
SHE CALLED HERSELF AN
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER COVERING
COVID-19.
SHE JUST ISN’T WILLING TO
INVESTIGATE OR REPORT ON
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT HURT HER
TENDER FEELINGS.
DR. SAFIRE, I COME TO YOU.
>> L, HARRIS, THE MOST PLAUSIBLE
THEORY WHEN YOU HAVE ANY
OUTBREAK, NATURAL ALL OVER WITH
ANIMALS AND HUMANS WAS TO GET A
COME OF THAT HAPPENS.
BUT YOU CANNOT DENY THE
COINCIDENCE AND THE STRANGE
OCCURRENCES THAT WENT ON AT THE
WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY JUST
8 MILES DOWN THE ROAD FROM THIS
WET MARKET AND IT IS A MECCA,
THE CORONAVIRUS RESEARCH LAB OF
THE WORLD AND WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
STARTED LOOKING AT CERTAIN
THINGS, YOU KNOW, A LOT WENT ON
SO JUST BEING ABLE TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS WAS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE LAB LEAKS HAPPEN, THIS
WOULDN’T BE THE FIRST TIME IT
HAPPENED, IT HAPPENED IN CHINA,
RUSSIA, THE UNITED STATES WITH A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PATHOGENS SO
YOU HAVE TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
BUT IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP MENTIONED IT,
ANTI-TRUMP’S AND TURNED IT INTO
SOMETHING THAT IT WASN’T AND
ANYBODY WHO GAVE ANY CREDENCE TO
THAT THEORY WAS DEEMED
ANTISCIENCE >> Harris:
INCLUDING YOU.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON, I WANT TO ASK
THE TEAM TO PROP UP WHAT THEY
CAN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BECAUSE
LAST JULY, "DR. SAFIRE SAID SHE
DID NOT BELIEVE THAT FAUCI
ENGINEER THE CORONAVIRUS BUT SHE
ALSO SAID THAT THERE WERE
SEVERAL THEORIES ABOUT ITS
ORIGINS AND ENDORSE THE THEORY
OF COVID HAS A 19 BEING MAN-MADE
WITHIN A LABORATORY.
A THEORY FOR WHICH THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE."
THEY DID HAVE TO TAKE THAT DOWN
AND TAKE IT BACK.
>> WELL, HARRIS, THE CORONAVIRUS
THAT’S BEEN CIRCULATING, THAT
LAB HAD THE MOST GENETICALLY
SIMILAR CORONAVIRUS IN IT AS THE
ONE CIRCULATING TODAY WHICH HAD
NOT BEEN FOUND IN THE WILD.
AND WE KNOW BASED ON THEIR
PUBLISHED RESEARCH THAT THEY
WERE GENETICALLY MODIFYING
CERTAIN CORONAVIRUS IS WITH
SIMILAR MUTATIONS THAT ARE IN
CARS COBEY.ALL OF THOSE CAN HAPP
NATURE BUT STILL TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS AND BECAUSE I KNOW
HISTORY CAN REPEAT ITSELF AND I
KNOW ACCIDENTAL LAB LEAKS CAN
HAPPEN THAT’S WHY I SAID I
COULDN’T SAY WITH CERTAINTY THAT
IT WASN’T FROM A LAB.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, KAYLEIGH,
I IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT OF YOU,
LISTENING TO GENERAL KEANE
YESTERDAY TALK ABOUT, 75 LABS IN
CHINA THAT THE UNITED STATES
KNOWS ABOUT, SOME OF THEM
WEAPONIZED, CERTAIN
BIOTECHNOLOGY, AND HE SAID THAT
THIS LAB IN WUHAN WAS ONE OF
THEM.
IT WAS NOT CLEAR IF THIS WAS ONE
OF THE VIRUSES THEY WERE TRYING
TO DO THAT WITH BUT THAT THEY DO
THAT AT THAT LAB.
>> Kayleigh: YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT AND LOOK, I WANT TO SAY
THIS AND I WILL GET TO THAT
POINT HERE, THE PRESS’ ROLE IN
THE SNOW THAT WE KNOW IT’S AN
INCREDIBLE THEORY, WE’VE KNOWN
IT SINCE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, FORMER PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES
DONALD TRUMP TOLD US THIS LAST
YEAR, THE PRESS CALLED HIM A
CONSPIRACY THEORIST AND EVEN IN
THE WAKE OF THIS FINDING BY
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY THAT
PEOPLE WERE SICK AT THE LAB,
EVEN IN THE WAKE OF THAT SOME
REPORTERS CAN’T BRING THEMSELVES
TO ADMIT THE CREDIBILITY OF THAT
THEORY, LIKE JONATHAN LEMAIRE
WHO SAID PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ENGAGING IN REVISIONIST HISTORY
BY SAYING HE WAS CITING THE LAB
IS THE ORIGIN.
IT’S NOT REVISIONIST HISTORY,
IT’S CALLED THE TRUTH AND MAGGIE
ABRAHAM SAID IT’S
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S BUT WE DIDN’T
BELIEVE HIM BECAUSE HE NEVER
SHOWED AS EVIDENCE.
MIKE POMPEO CAME OUT AND SAID
"HERE’S THE EVIDENCE."
HE LAID OUT THREE POINTS, THE
SIX MEMBERS OF THE LABORATORY
AND EXACTLY AS YOU JUST SAID,
THAT THIS INSTITUTE HAS HAD TIES
TO WORKING ON MILITARY PROJECTS
WITH THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
SO THERE WAS EVIDENCE, THE
REPORTERS JUST CHOSE TO IGNORE
IT.
>> Harris: AND I WANT TO GET
TOMORROW WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH
THE MEDIA, DAVID, I WILL COME TO
YOU ON THIS, CBS REPORTED
YESTERDAY AND MADE THIS
CONFESSION ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENT
SURROUNDING THE WUHAN LAB LEAK
THEORY, WATCH.
"IT’S A VINDICATION OF SORTS FOR
TRUMP-ERA OFFICIALS WHO LONG
ARGUED THEY BELIEVED THAT THIS
VIRUS ORIGINATED IN A LAB ONLY
TO BE DISMISSED IN PART BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THEIR ANTI-CHINA
RHETORIC AND YOU SAY WHAT?
>> David: IT HAS TO FIRST BE
NOTED THAT YOU HAVE BEEN ON THIS
SINCE DAY ONE, HARRIS, IN TRYING
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT AND
FIND ANSWERS.
THE QUESTION FOR OUR COUNTRY AND
OF THE MAY WANT TO START ASKING
PRESIDENT BIDEN THIS, WHAT STEPS
IS HE WILLING TO TAKE IF IT IS
DISCOVERED THAT THIS WAS
INTENTIONALLY DONE BY CHINA?
ARE WE GOING TO THROW THEM OUT
OF THE STOCK MARKET?
ARE WE GOING TO QUIT TAKING
INVESTMENTS FROM THEM, ARE WE
GOING TO SEEK TO SABOTAGE THEIR
BIOLOGICAL RESEARCH?
WHAT STEPS IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILLING TO TAKE IF CHINA DID
THIS INTENTIONALLY TO CAUSE A
WORLD PANDEMIC?
>> Harris: MAYBE WE HAVE AN
IDEA, KENNEDY, THANK YOU FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT, MY TWITTER
FEED LOOKS LIKE A STICKER BOX
BECAUSE A GOVERNMENT WAS POSTING
STICKERS.
STICK A CDC STICKER ON IT AND
DR. SIEGEL WITH OUR TEAM JUST
SAID KEEP ASKING YOUR QUESTIONS,
DON’T BACK DOWN.
SO, KENNEDY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHERE WE’VE COME IN THE
INFORMATION, THERE WERE CERTAIN
THINGS THAT WE REALLY DID KNOW
ENOUGH ABOUT TO ASK QUESTIONS
AND WHEN YOU SHUTDOWN THE MEDIA
FROM ASKING QUESTIONS, YOU DO SO
ENDANGER THE PUBLIC.
I WONDER IF WE COULD HAVE ASKED
THE QUESTIONS EVEN BEFORE WE
REALLY KNEW WHAT WE WERE DEALING
WITH ABOUT CHINA BUT WORDS LIKE
"XENOPHOBIC" WOULD POP UP EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE FACT-BASED,
EVIDENCE-BASED TYPE QUESTIONS.
>> Kennedy: WHAT DID DR. FAUCI
KNOW ABOUT THIS RESEARCH AND
WHAT HE KNOW ABOUT WEAPONIZING
CERTAIN VIRUSES WITH THE CHINA
STEAM AT COMMUNIST CHINESE
MILITARY PARTICULARLY IN THAT
LAB?
THERE WAS A LOT MORE THAT HAD
BEEN GLEANED BY INTELLIGENCE,
THE CDC, THE NIH AND DR. FAUCI’S
INSTITUTE AND THEY WERE NOT
FORTHCOMING AND THEY WERE VERY
ADAMANT THAT THIS WAS ANIMAL TO
HUMAN TRANSMISSION AND IF THAT
IS NOT THE CASE, NOT ONLY DOES
CHINA HAVE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, AND I TALKED ABOUT
THIS LAST NIGHT ON MY
FOX BUSINESS SHOW, WE SHOULD NOT
AS AN INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY BE
GRANTING THEM THE OLYMPICS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SAID, CHINA
HAS SAID THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN FURTHER
INVESTIGATIONS WITH THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION, THEY ARE
DONE, THEY’VE DONE ENOUGH.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH
BECAUSE ALL THESE QUESTIONS
REMAIN SO WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DO TO MAKE SURE THIS DOESN’T
HAPPEN AGAIN, WE DON’T KNOW WHAT
ELSE IS IN THOSE OTHER LABS AND
THAT SHOULD TERRIFY PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THIS WAS, IN TERMS OF
THE VIRUS, JUICED UP IN
RAND PAUL’S LANGUAGE, THIS IS
PRETTY MILD SO I DON’T WANT TO
SEE THE VIRUSES ESCAPE THOSE
LABS IN THE FUTURE AND ALSO IN
THE UNITED STATES, I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT PEOPLE LIKE DR. FAUCI
KNEW AND WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT
AND WHEN DID THEY FEEL IT WAS
OKAY TO LIE TO US AND LET 100s
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE DIE IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> Harris: LOOK, KENNEDY, WE
GOT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT WITH YOU YESTERDAY AND
DAVID, TO YOUR POINT, IT WAS
BREAKING NEWS DURING THIS HOUR
OF THE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS TOPIC, ASKED ABOUT IT
AND WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS
RELEASED THE 90 DAY REVIEW WANT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE ORIGINS AS
BEST THEY CAN BECAUSE YOU KNOW,
HAS REPORTED ON THE PANEL, CHINA
IS NOT EXACTLY SAYING COME ON
IN.
AND HE SAID, YEAH, HE WILL
RELEASE THAT UNLESS THERE’S
SOMETHING IN IT THAT HE WAS
UNAWARE OF.
SO MY QUESTION WOULD BE, DAVID,
WHAT DO YOU ALREADY KNOW THAT
YOU’RE NOT TELLING US?
LAST WORDS.
>> David: IS A GREAT QUESTION
AND THAT’S WHY SECRETARY POMPEO
WANTED TO INVESTIGATE IT AND
OTHERS WANTED TO INVESTIGATE IT
AND FINALLY WE ARE GOING TO GET
AN INVESTIGATION AND MAYBE
AMERICANS WILL GET SOME ANSWERS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, ALL THE MORE
REASON WHY MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND
PRESCRIPTION MEDICINES NEED TO
BE MADE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Kennedy: THE EVIDENCE IS
GONE AT THIS POINT, I HATE TO
BREAK IT TO PEOPLE BUT IS NOT
THERE ANYMORE.
>> Harris: YEAH, DECOUPLING
FROM CHINA PARTICULARLY ON
PHARMACEUTICALS AND VACUUMING UP
POTENTIALLY ALL THE PPE AS WE
WERE ALL TRYING TO GET IT
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY KNEW IT WAS
COMING.
DR. SAFIRE, YOU’VE WRITTEN A
BOOK CALLED "PANIC ATTACK" AND
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT A
LITTLE BIT LATER THIS HOUR
BECAUSE YOU REALLY DELVED INTO
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
AMERICANS HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AND
THINK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR